Apple's iPhone 15 lineup is currently in
the final stages of production as we get
closer and closer to its September
release date but I keep seeing a problem
that's been bothering me more and more
as the years go by people are still
buying regular iPhone models instead of
Pro Models despite them becoming worse
each year in terms of value the iPhone
14 was already really bad since it gets
the old a15 chip the Notch and a general
lack of features but with the iPhone 15
lineup I'm afraid this is the year where
everyone should avoid the regular models
and finally go pro because we all know
once you go pro you can't go back and
it's for a dang good reason which I'm
going to explain in this video now I
know what you're gonna say the Pro
Models are more expensive and yes they
definitely are but my take is that you
should rather skip an entire regular
model upgrade and spend the next year
saving up cash to make up the difference
so that next year you can afford to buy
a pro model instead or better yet if
you're planning on buying a regular
model iPhone 15 later this year start
saving cash right now for the next five
months so that you can get the pro model
and if you're surprised by how adamant I
am about people going for the pro
instead you won't be by the end of this
video so let's jump right into it ever
since the iPhone 7 plus that gained a
telephoto camera and portrait mode for
the first time Apple's been giving their
larger or higher end phones more
features but it really started to get
nuts when Apple released the iPhone 11
Pro boasting a better display better
battery life stainless steel frame
better water resistance cameras and more
then with the 12 Pro they added lidar
and night mode across all the cameras as
well as extra RAM storage and of course
a better and brighter display but the
year 2021 is where the pros really
started to stand out but before I get
into that I've got to show you guys the
best pair of shoes I've ever had in my
life from our sponsor vesi which are
perfect for the rainy season because
they're 100 waterproof meaning you can
walk straight through puddles without
soaking your shoes and finally I can
walk through wet grass without ending up
with wet socks for the rest of the day
thanks to the waterproof knit material
called dime attacks which is breathable
warm and durable they also sent me their
new storm burst sneaker which was
perfect for when I went paintballing in
a muddy field so they're great for
hiking or even as waterproof work boots
and the best part is that you can rinse
them off and clean them under the sink
like my wife's vessey boots which she
loves and the inside stays fully dry all
of them are very grippy and comfortable
as well so check out these vessies and
other styles at vesi.com
and use the code Max deck to get 15 off
your entire order today the iPhone 13
Pro had add thinner bezels a smaller
Notch higher graphics performance and
best of all the pro model got a 120
hertz Pro motion display basically
making it feel twice as smooth and it's
the number one reason I'll never go back
to a regular iPhone ever again and then
of course with the 14 pro Apple just
went nuts by only giving the pro model
three brand new game-changing features
the a16 bionic chip the new Dynamic
Island that finally replaced the Notch
and of course the always-on display
that's almost two times brighter than
the 14 in sunlight not only that but the
cameras are much better with bigger
sensors macro mode and 4K cinematic mode
this basically proved to me that Apple
wants more people to buy Pro Models and
with the growing list of differences I'm
actually shocked people are still going
for the regular ones especially since
the price of the pros have remained
unchanged for years but now with the
iPhone 15 lineup apple is going to be
pushing the boundaries even further so
let's get into the leaks and changes we
should expect first of all we all know
that Apple's iPhone 15 Pro will be
coming with a brand new titanium finish
which looks absolutely beautiful and
it'll help keep the weight of the iPhone
down but the regular 15 is going to
stick to the same old aluminum design
once again we've also had a ton of leaks
surrounding the new solid state buttons
on the Pro Models and although we won't
get the unified volume button until next
year the leakers have confirmed that we
will be getting a brand new action
button which will be programmable
finally replacing the mute switch that
we've had for the last 16 years but
guess what the regular iPhone 15 will
not be getting it on top of that the Pro
Models will get a jump to 8 gigs of RAM
just like Apple's M1 and M2 Max leaving
the regular 15 with only six gigs Wi-Fi
6E is also another feature that's coming
you guessed it only to the Pro Models
and while it's really nice that the
entire iPhone 15 lineup will finally be
getting a new USBC port to replace the
decade old lightning the regular models
will be limited to the same old
incredibly slow USB 2.0 speeds the Pro
Models will be the only ones getting
record-breaking thin display bezels only
1.55 millimeters thinner than on any
other smartphone ever made those going
for the pro Max model will also enjoy
the iPhone's first ever Periscope camera
lens enabling further Zoom range with
higher quality while the regular 15
won't even get a basic telephoto lens at
all on top of that the 15 Pro will be
getting the a17 bionic chip making it
the first phone in the world with a
three nanometer base chip from tsmc
which is set to improve Energy
Efficiency by 35 to help save battery
life and that's of course only coming to
the pro model since the regular 15 will
be getting the current third generation
5 nanometer based a16 Channel not only
that but the three nanometer Tech and
the a17 will help push out more
performance since the efficiency will
help it run cool and that's happening at
the same time as we're supposed to be
getting a huge GPU core redesign That
was supposed to happen on the a16 but
got delayed until the a17 so the
difference in performance between the
iPhone 15 Pro's a17 chip and the iPhone
15s a16 is gonna be huge much bigger
than we currently have right now and
then of course we have to consider all
of the other changes that the pro model
already enjoys like the much brighter
display the always-on display feature
the better battery life the better
camera quality and features like the
lidar scanner and most of all the 120
hertz Pro motion feature and making
things worse for the regular models that
once when he hears this display
apparently isn't coming to a regular
iPhone until the iPhone 17 in 2025 yes
another two years from now so if you
haven't upgraded to a pro model yet it's
literally the best time to do so so now
that we're in 2023 we should expect at
least a dozen extra pro model features
that you won't be getting on the regular
iPhone 15 and I think many people just
don't realize that there are that many
differences now you've got to be really
careful and warn your friends and family
because this year apple is going to try
extra hard to make it seem like they're
really not that different at all for
example we just got a leak saying that
the regular iPhone 15 and 15 plus models
will be coming with the same frosted
glass that has been exclusive to the Pro
Models ever since the 11 Pro so it might
not look and feel that different on top
of that the regular 15 models will now
finally ditch the notch and come with
the dynamic Island which will make them
look quite similar once again but do not
be deceived by Apple they're way
different as I showed you in this video
and the regular 15 models will be much
cheaper for Apple to produce now on the
flip side if you look at the huge list
of features the Pro Models are going to
be getting this year it's actually quite
surprising and exciting now I do expect
the price to get hiked a bit like maybe
a hundred dollars more for each pro
model but it's gonna be worth it
considering the huge amount of bonus
features with the Periscope camera being
the one I'm really excited for alongside
the new a17 bionic chip leading to even
better battery life and those super thin
bezels and don't forget the USBC port
with faster transfer speeds on top of
that I'm personally hopeful that Apple
will finally allow the 48 megapixel
camera to be used in portrait mode for
super high quality portraits which will
fix the final little complaint I have
with my 14 pro Max now if you totally
disagree with my thoughts in this video
let me know down in the comment section
below but if you enjoyed it click the
circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out one of those two videos right over
there thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next one
foreign